ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben was also wir dürfen
gar nicht langer zeit von ihnen wird
mein gott
wir dürfen gar nicht an zeit für den
mann lieben freunde denn wir haben
wieder extrem viel auf der liste fürs
heutige video was wir erledigen müssen
da die schildkröte erste und auch
wichtigste sache die für heute auf dem
plan steht ist dass wir hier in dem
dörflein einen weiteren dorfbewohner
mitnehmen so dass wir unseren paaren
können den wir ja schon auf unserer
insel haben die frage ist jetzt wie ich
denn da hinkriegt habe ich jetzt nicht
dabei ich werde einfach so wie beim
letzten mal machen und hier so einen
kleinen weg buddeln so dass ich ihnen
direkt hier innsbruck platzieren kann
und einfach erwartet er hat schon beruf
gerber
den kann ich nicht dann nehme ich noch
mit whisky oder erfolgreich meine lieben
freunde ich weiß dass wir da vorne noch
das schaf stehen haben das kommt
irgendwann auch noch mit zu insel
allerdings erstmal den dorf guck mal das
ist ein neues zuhause
warum hätte das jeder so wir halten hier
vorne in unserem boot stieg an und ich
mache mein brot kaputt sodass der du
kommst jetzt mit der wirtschaft
angekommen auf unserer insel ich habe ja
extra in dem häuschen was ich in der
letzten folge gebaut habe drei betten
hingestellt so dass auf jeden fall genug
platz wäre wenn sie sich paaren möchten
müssen der andere direkt neuen beruf
[Musik]
so riecht nach fisch stinkt keine ahnung
warum der gute einfach jetzt random
fischer geworden ist wenn ihr da was
wisst anschreibt beginnt in die
kommentare ich nehme jetzt allerdings
mal dass weizen hier raus und macht er
daraus brot und das wird mir die
kommentare geschrieben dass die das
brauchen um sich zu paaren
irgendwie komisch dass die brot brauchen
um kinder zu kriegen ich habe keine
ahnung wie viel die brauchen aber ich
habe genug von daher habe ich jetzt
einfach mal hier so ein halbes deck
gemacht hier
[Musik]
ich weiß ein halbes deck brote oder geht
einfach weg jede garten es ist kein
schimmel brot in einem youtube-video
sich dazu geguckt hat das geklappt
hier nimmt im brot gerade aus dem bett
geschleudert worden
weiter sind jahre später so dankeschön
der herr ich weiß nicht ob er sich jetzt
das andere besucht aber er hat mein
gebäude auf jeden fall verlassen
wir begleiten den willicher einfach mal
wird er das andere bett finden wir der
sich mit der anerkennung
[Musik]
wir lassen die ball
ich gehe doch schon einmal kurzen
kleinen blick hier rein werden ob die
zwei da wirklich liegen also er liegt da
auf jeden fall
die andere musste die andere als alleine
[Musik]
jetzt stehe ich gar nichts mehr ich habe
alles so gemacht wie es im internet
stand allerdings können an der stelle
auch einen kurzen blick auf unsere
schildkröteneier hier werfen es nämlich
hier bist du du kannst nicht hier
fischen da ist kein wasser es mir jetzt
auch egal die werden das auf dauer schon
irgendwie gedribbelt kriegen ich meine
die haben ja auch das bedürfnis sich
irgendwie fortzupflanzen stadt atmet
mitgenommen ein neuer morgen angebrochen
in meiner minecraft welt und die bahn
war wissen dann creeper in der
zwischenzeit wo sich meine beiden
dorfbewohner ein bisschen kennenlernen
und keine ahnung vielleicht etwas essen
gehen ich will jetzt ja auch nicht
stressen dass sie die die jetzt direkt
irgendwie ein kind raus hassel oder so
kommt wie süß hier lernt euch kennen
schön freut liebsten das geräusch
[Musik]
und egal was habe ich getan ich habe
keine ahnung ob das eigentlich habe ich
mir extrem viele to boost für heute auf
geschrieben weil ich dachte die brauchen
halt ein bisschen weil die sich kennen
lernen wollen und so weiter und so fort
allerdings hast du mir die isu hat
einfach mal durch hier wollte ich
nämlich die kartoffeln abbauen und eine
kleine eichen stufe hinsetzen denn mir
wurde gesagt luca pass auf dass der
eisen golem nicht in ein feld kommt weil
er kann diese tür nicht öffnen
deswegen die stufe und da kann ich
einfach drüber hüpfen wunsch dann wollte
ich auch hier vorne einen baum hinsetzen
der hoffentlich ein bisschen größer so
ich habe jetzt tatsächlich 14
knochenmehl daraus bekommen und daher
kommt der gar das kann nicht sein dass
so ein scheiß baum kommt da jetzt bei
raus oder was an diesem baum da unten
werde ich jetzt allerdings dass luxus
schild dran hängen weil das hier auf
jeden fall gefehlt hat so dass luft
schulterklopfer sagen würde was ich auch
noch machen wollte waren ein paar neue
bruchsteinen stufen denn der weg hier
fast so ein bisschen ab ich muss immer
so ein bisschen komisch aus reichen von
er packe ich jetzt einfach auch mal so
ein ding hier den weg muss ich
eigentlich auch noch mal ein bisschen
schöner machen weil das er jetzt der
eingang ist zu dem haus von den village
dann kann ich den weg auch hier
eigentlich so ein bisschen wieder
wegmachen komme dass für richtige insel
reparatur folge also hier geht das ganze
jetzt so lang dann macht er hier so eine
kleine kurve zu dem häuschen hin
ihr packe ich das so hin da mache ich
das hier noch eben weg dann sind glaube
ich ein bisschen klima aus warum fällt
mich jetzt auf dass der gar nicht mittig
ist setzen wir also den kompletten weg
einfach ein stückchen rüber nach links
dann sieht das alles auch ein bisschen
proportionaler und symmetrische aus hier
zack zack das machen alles noch in der
richtigen insel reparatur folge dass das
alles ein bisschen schöner aussieht
allerdings erstreckt sich der weg dann
tatsächlich hier lang hier lang hier
lang geht hier so ein bisschen gerader
langen den baum hier zählen wir dann
auch mal das hier sieht auf jeden fall
jetzt deutlich schöner aus als vorher
klar der baum das wird nachher auch noch
ein bisschen besser aussieht
ich will gar nicht mehr mit euch passt
zu tun das ist mein haus hole mal den
chef damals nicht in club reingekommen
hat jetzt komme ich nicht mal mein
eigenes haus rein was ich auch noch
machen wollte war dieser eichenholz
falltüren ersetzen durch fichtenholz
falschen es gibt glaube ich ein bisschen
schöner aus als wenn ich da diese
eichenholz fallschirm habe zum sitzen
und das hier kommt auch noch weg hab ich
nämlich auch was überlegt was ich hier
vorne vorhabe ist eine schaukel denkt
euch jetzt wahrscheinlich herum eine
schaukel keine ahnung was ich hatte da
irgendwie so eine idee die zu machen und
habe ein video gesehen wo sogar diese 1
vorgestellt wurden in minecraft und
verdrängt genau da wo ich die schaukel
bauen welche vorne verbinden wir die
kette dann mit den falltüren hier oben
drauf kommt auch noch eine und die hält
sich fest an dem laub was sich hier so
ein bisschen weiter bauer das habe ich
zwar noch aus der kiste geholt dass das
hier so ein bisschen schöner und
natürlich aussieht dass ich dort so
natürlich sieht hier fast gar nichts
mehr auf der insel aus aber ich versuche
so ein bisschen so zu halten hier zack
zack vielleicht noch und dann können uns
den ganzen apparat jetzt mal anschauen
ok also von ihr vorne sieht das jetzt so
aus mit der chance entdeckt das wird
echt langsam lebendig unsere insel hier
meine intention war dann auf jeden fall
dass man hier einfach auf die schaukel
gehen kann und dann kann man den knopf
zu drücken wie nennt man kaninchen im
fitnessstudio ja wieder in panik
hier vorne kann ich übrigens auch mal
ein bisschen mit dem ball arbeiten dann
sieht das ja auch noch mal alles ein
bisschen schöner aus auch hier vorne so
eine ecke das haben wir alles neu
bepflanzen den letzten folge hier zack
zack zack hier fehlt noch ein bisschen
war es die schildkröteneier sind noch
immer gleiche passiert doch irgendwie
nichts da es tut mir unfassbar leid aber
ich muss den luke roberts auch nochmal
abfällen und einfach darauf hoffen dass
hier ein richtig großer baum jetzt raus
wachsen wird ich weiß nicht ob jetzt
meint mir ist wieder weg ich pflanze
vorne jetzt wirklich einfach alles mit
kartoffeln voll weil ihr in den
kommentaren ja zu mir meinte das
gebratene kartoffeln gebackenen
kartoffeln einen deutlich besser heilen
als weizen et cetera alle zusammen
deswegen den rest auf jeden fall hier
vorne wieder in die kiste reihen die
weizenkörner brauche ich nicht das
weizen brauche ich auch nicht und die
anderen kartoffeln kann ich auf jeden
fall doch kann ich mit hoch nehmen kann
ich auf jeden fall ein bisschen beraten
aber den apfel werde ich bin ich essen
verrotten rhein und die giftige ryans
akteur zu und das ist echt geil wäre mir
fast keine monster mehr um ein
gottenheim herzinfarkt bekommen weil
wohl geschlafen freunde und haben heute
schon wieder um gottes in zombie da ist
der wille gott man will ja nicht angst
verzeichnen
das wiso flitzen findet so rost oder
gott ich habe noch einen weiteren plan
für die heutige folge beziehungsweise
waren das alles meine warum gilt wie
überall aber nicht oben die ja ich
verstehe es nicht
ich habe mir eigentlich ganz ganz viele
sachen aufgeschrieben ich dachte ich
möchte diesen riesigen hohlraum den wir
haben nutzen um hier eine kleine
zuckerrohr vom rhein zu bauen
das ist tatsächlich auch insel reparatur
dass das ist in der reparatur wir machen
gerade insel reparatur jedem insel
reparatur einen shot da sind wir also
sieht jetzt nicht wunderschön aus ich
muss es noch ein bisschen schöner machen
allerdings habe ich hinten schon mal
fast alles zugemacht mit sand das muss
natürlich alles noch ein bisschen
schöner werden hier das wird auch noch
zugemacht und dann ist ja ich habe auch
irgendwie eine vorletzten folge
vielleicht alles zuccheros papier
gemacht das war nicht so schlau meine
farbe allerdings wird demnächst dann
alles voll stehen mit zuckerrohr und das
können dann wiederum nehmen um daraus
papier zu machen und das papier können
wir nehmen und das mit den bildern
traden dafür können wir dann bücher
erhalten und so weiter und so fort also
das ist auf jeden fall mein plan ihr
könnt mir gerne die kommentare schreiben
auch das umsetzbar ist oder ob ich mir
irgendwie zu große hoffnung mache dass
ich da dann irgendwie trasse
verzauberungen bekomme und so weiter und
so fort
aber ich habe bin da eigentlich ganz
guten gewissens jetzt kann ich auch hier
noch ein bisschen weiter die insel
reparatur mache ich hab mir nämlich
gedacht ich mache jetzt gar nicht in der
extra folge von wegen die fed der insel
reparatur folge die muss wahrscheinlich
allerdings bei der trotzdem kommen aber
hier alles ein bisschen schöner ist er
glaube ich im interesse aller und dann
mach ich ja auch noch mal eine reihe
erde und haben wir unseren kleinen
eingang zur höhle die man dann aber im
nachhinein gar nicht mehr sieht sondern
dann kommt man rein und sie bahn
sogar ohr was du bisher noch nicht da
ist aber das kommt noch jetzt kommen wir
allerdings zu einer sache meine lieben
freunde die wirte sehr sehr sehr sehr
viele von euch freuen und auch sehr sehr
viele
danke bund zwar ist es die portal insel
die ich da hinten hin bauen wollte denn
meine lieben freunde trommelwirbel ihr
müsse jetzt anschnallen in der nächsten
episode gehen wir in die hölle
ich kann es auch noch nicht so richtig
glauben hier schon wie das und karg baum
gewachsen alter was soll das denn das
kann nicht sein ich will hier einen
riesigen baum damit wir vorne darüber
klettern kann und damit wir mal soll ein
online großenbaum
jetzt kommt die noch kleinerer scheiße
baum überlegt malta das erste mal dass
sich einfach in die verdammte hölle gehe
in diesem projekt ich habe ein bisschen
schiss viele meinten zum lokal du musst
dir auf jeden fall eine krasse rüstung
machen und sodann sonst wieder komplett
sterben aber ich bin ja erfahrener
minecraft spieler und weiß um meine
skills die nicht warten sind ich werde
hier jetzt auf jeden fall so eine kleine
ja portal inselbahn ich finde es ein
bisschen schönheit wenn das portal
liegen im keller steht oder das ist
schon cool aus unsere inseln was wir
überlegen wie sich das alles entwickelt
hat von der ersten folge an ihr fordert
wird sich noch normalen bruchstein hin
dann hier immer noch ein stein ziegel
dann wieder normalen bruchstein dann
wieder einen stein ziegel dann hier
vorne einfach mal einen posten hat diese
tiere erschreckt mich jeden tag aufs
neue der moment der wahrheit freunde ich
packe hier das obsidian hin
die portal insel steht das portal steht
ich habe mein feuerzeug nehme es in die
hand
das portal ab
[Gelächter]
die versuchung liegt sehr nah da jetzt
einfach mein schritt rhein zu setzen ich
werde das allerdings nicht machen
sondern in der nächsten folge meine
lieben freunde und dort werden wir dann
wirklich die komplette folge langen in
der hölle verbringen ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt
ich bin auch gespannt auf eure tipps was
immer noch sagen werdet weil ganz ganz
viele haben schon geschrieben
ich bin gespannt wenn luca in netter
geht weil da geht es richtig ab wohl
seit den letzten updates ich geh jetzt
einfach eine runde panel ich freue mich
mega auf die nächste folge meine lieben
freunde und diese mega kranke höhlen
folge kommt übermorgen am sonntag um 20
uhr online hier auf dem youtube-kanal
wenn ihr das also nicht verpassen wollt
dann abonniert main kanal aktiviert die
glocke damit die direkte nachrichten um
bekommt wenn das video online ist und
stellt euch fett im kalender ein
das wird krass ich freue mich und jetzt
voller vorfreude schlafen guten
[Musik]